greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
let's just talk about another particular
oddity that bothers me about your
holiday presents am I to understand that
you give presents to your offspring
simply because they are your offspring
why merely because they have been good
or you're out there supposed to be good
to begin with
what is this rewarding of what they're
already supposed to do if the mailman
gets your mail on time do you give him a
cookie no secure dog on it why do these
little pipsqueaks deserve a present
anyway you're the one who created them
carry them in your room
push the giant dome light skulls out of
your tiny birth canal
I see videos it's quite horrific clearly
they should be giving a present to you
and in return you shall not kill them on
Krypton children who are good are given
the reward of knowing they are good
children who are bad are dead evolution
has weeded them out they have no place
among us the reward for being good on
Krypton is that you get to live that is
a good reward my friend they shall not
forget it of course it doesn't do much
now with a blown up planet but I blame
global warming for that one the globe
was so warm and exploded and once more
how do you give the presents you store
them under the tree you mercilessly
killed you know that tree that's trust
like a pine needle a prostitute and what
you don't stuff under that dirty
decaying corpse of a tree you put in
somebody's sock here's an idea
be practical why don't you buy some
socks and then put them in the sock that
way you've doubled your socks no I do
not approve of this gift-giving at all
final sum up presents have no place in
designed only in people's republic of
houston it shall be replaced with more
practical things like socks maybe a new
pair of slacks pay your electric bill or
finally putting that back deck together
that's a prison your child can get
started on I have spoken this is General
Zod and you will all kneel before me you
and your sucks